un projet de loi qui prêtent à
controverse maintenant il est discuté
depuis quelques heures à l'assemblée
nationale les français pris en otages à
l'étranger dans des zones à risques
devront payer eux-mêmes les frais
engagés pour leur libération
face aux protestations bernard kouchner
a précisé tout à l'heure que les
journalistes et les humanitaires ne
seront pas concernés hakim abdel khaleq
zine dine boudaoud thierry breton
des commandos marine et trois navires de
guerre français pour libérer les otages
du tanit au large de la somalie une zone
réputée très dangereuse même opérations
de secours un an avant
au même endroit sur le ponant cette
fois-ci 22 français sont libérés grâce à
la marine nationale à chaque fois l'état
prend en charge le coût des secours
souvent très élevé le gouvernement
souhaite désormais faire payer aux
otages les frais de leur libération sont
visés dans le projet de loi les
personnes qui se sont délibérément
exposées sauf motif légitime tiré de
leur activité professionnelle ou d'une
situation d'urgence à des risques
qu'elles ne pouvaient ignorer un texte
trop floue selon ce député qui
souhaitent une liste des personnes
protéger les journalistes
les professionnels des médias et leurs
collaborateurs les intervenants
humanitaires
les universitaires les chercheurs de
façon à ce qu'il ne soit pas mis dans
cette situation que signifierait une
démocratie dans laquelle on demanderait
aux journalistes de démontrer la
légitimité du motif qui a fait que ils
ont encouru un danger pour le ministre
des affaires étrangères le texte vise
surtout les agences de voyages et les
touristes irresponsable il ne remet pas
en cause selon lui la liberté de la
presse
le n'ayez aucune crainte c'est pas moi
qui vais dire que les journalistes ne
doivent pas prendre de risque ni les
humanités rouge évidemment pas plus
simple de l'écrire
non parce que lorsque vous l'écrivez
vous oubliez toujours sur la liste
ce projet de loi intervient quelques
semaines après la polémique sur les
frais engagés pour retrouver les deux
journalistes de france 3 toujours
retenus en afghanistan dans l'est